Traductor: Gisela Giardino
Revisor: Helene Batt
A los siete años, mi padre me llevó
a un concierto de música clásica
por primera vez
y salí llorando.
Tocaban la Quinta Sinfonía de Beethoven.
(Música)
¿Cómo preparas a un niño antes de que
vaya a un concierto de música clásica
por primera vez?
Unos días antes, nos sentamos a escuchar
una grabación que él tenía.
Y ahí me explicó
un par de cosas sencillas,
como por ejemplo
la insistencia del "ta, ta, ta, tan"
a lo largo del primer movimiento.
Pero que, además, regresa
más tarde en la sinfonía.
Que esta sinfonía
tenía cuatro movimientos.
O que el final de esta sería una victoria.
Una victoria humana, musical,
concreta o abstracta.
Que lo que comienza con un insistente
y sentencioso llamado,
se convierte en un triunfo
lleno de validación y optimismo.
Incluso jugábamos a un juego:
cada vez que comenzara una sección
de la que habíamos hablado,
yo apretaría su mano en señal
de reconocimiento.
Con esta información llegué al teatro.
Esto, y la natural curiosidad
me cargaron de expectativas.
Por una parte estaba tan concentrado
disfrutando de la música,
pero también de la experiencia
de estar ahí:
el público atento, la orquesta numerosa,
el sonido apasionado...
Todo iba según lo había anticipado,
hasta que de pronto ocurre algo increíble.
Algo que hasta el día de hoy considero
uno de los momentos musicales
más perfectos jamás escritos,
un milagro.
La música, hace un rato
venía repitiendo un gesto,
(Toca el piano)
¿Lo identifican?
Pero además, una sucesión de acordes
que me hacían pensar que después de esto,
seguramente, vendría esto.
Una suerte de "sentido común musical".
Pero no hay nada milagroso en eso.
Humildemente, esa resolución
podría haberla escrito yo,
y de paso terminamos el movimiento
y dejamos que la gente tosa tranquila
y compulsivamente
o que revisen su teléfono.
Pero esta música no la escribí yo.
Y Beethoven es Beethoven por algo.
Retrocedamos unos segundos:
(Música)
Todo esto sigue un patrón,
y ya sabemos cómo debería concluir.
¿Y esto? Esto no me lo esperaba.
Un niño diría: como que te engaña…
Esa nota salida de otro universo
sonoro sorprende.
La música, el ritmo, late apenas
al filo de su extinción.
Pero poco a poco se estabiliza,
como dando señales vitales.
De ese impulso brotan los violines y
una línea melódica errática, intermitente,
insegura incluso, hasta que
también encuentra consistencia.
De esa forma la música cautiva
nuestra atención.
Es un momento cargado de la promesa
de un inminente desenlace.
De ese algo que sabemos que va a ocurrir,
que sin darnos cuenta, ya lo esperábamos.
(Música)
Después de eso mi padre me miró
y me abrazó emocionado.
Yo sollozaba.
Lo mire y le dije:
"no sé por qué estoy llorando,
si no es tristeza lo que siento".
Ese momento marcó mi vida.
Fue ahí, a los siete años,
que decidí dedicar mi vida a la música.
Porque quería recrear
ese momento, entenderlo
y después compartir y contagiarlo.
Veamos si lo podemos lograr aquí y ahora,
yo creo que es contagioso.
Cuando les conté de esta nota inesperada,
de esa llave a nuevas opciones
que finalmente se transforman
en la puerta a este gran triunfo musical,
lo que hice fue puntualizar un fenómeno
muy simple y al mismo tiempo muy común
en la vida misma: las expectativas.
Si el tercer movimiento hubiese
efectivamente terminado así,
(Toca el piano)
nuestra percepción de lo ocurrido
se mantendría dentro
de ciertos parámetros de expectativas.
Básicamente recibimos lo que esperamos.
La música concluye,
el público se acomoda, tose.
(Risas)
Los instrumentistas se relajan un segundo
hasta que el director vuelve a levantar
las manos en señal de embestida
para arremeter con el último movimiento.
Funciona.
La música impacta de todas formas.
Pero no es lo mismo.
Esa transición que escribió Beethoven
no solo cumple la función de conectar
una música con otra, sino que genera
otro tipo de expectativas.
Desde esa nota inesperada,
hasta la búsqueda de nueva estabilidad
en el ritmo, la melodía, la armonía
y esa textura que crece
y desemboca en algo mayor.
Pero en el intertanto,
nuestra mente reacciona.
Comienza a buscar alternativas,
escenarios posibles.
Y Beethoven lo sabe.
Por eso esa disolución y divagar
de la música nos confunde.
Y esa confusión genera expectativas
que son mezcla de predicción
y disposición a seguir siendo sorprendidos
ya que la misma música nos demostró
que todo es posible.
En un nivel extra musical se parece
a mi propia actitud
antes y durante el concierto.
La información de mi padre
fue un incentivo para llegar al teatro
lleno de expectativas.
A reconocer lo que ya sabía, a constatar.
Pero una vez que me sorprendió,
ya todo era posible.
El poder evocador de la música proviene
en gran medida de su capacidad de generar,
prolongar, suspender, o incluso
traicionar expectativas.
¿Pero qué esperamos de ella?
¿de la música misma?
Una melodía y un acompañamiento.
Una idea que se presenta, dialoga
y encuentra un cierre.
Una nueva idea, más jocosa.
Todo apacible, esperable.
Expectativas cumplidas.
¡Ajá!
Giro inesperado.
¡Drama! ¡Opera!
No se veía venir.
Porque es más fácil predecir
desde la consistencia.
Como en este preludio de Bach.
Estamos diseñados para buscar estabilidad
y asegurarnos a una predicción.
Se gatillan asociaciones y la memoria
saca conclusiones.
La consistencia nos permite
anticipar y acertar.
Y una de las fuentes de placer
al escuchar música
es cuando nuestras
expectativas se cumplen.
Pero, ¿y cuando perdemos
el control de la predicción?
¿Cuando no se cumplen?
Gran recurso del romanticismo.
Franz Liszt juega con este sorprender.
Una melodía apasionada, arrebatada,
que comienza un viaje.
Pero regresa.
Y ahí, cuando todo parecía ir por
el mismo camino, seguro, predecible.
¡Esto!
Se abre una puerta, otra alternativa.
Que desestabiliza, pero fascina.
¡Otra más!
Fue como encontrar opciones
que no se veían posibles.
Y ese desafío a las expectativas
nos seduce.
O un contraste.
Mahler sentencia:
"Oscura es la vida. Oscura es la muerte".
Seria y desesperanzada,
la música toma un nuevo giro.
Pero además, esta música
tiene un dejo de movimiento,
de baile, de vals.
Y ¡claro!
el estilo, la tradición y la herencia
también generan expectativas.
Porque Mahler es heredero
de toda una tradición vienesa
donde esta música es parte de su ADN.
¿Y del de nosotros?
¿O no se sonrieron algunos
al reconocer este vals de Strauss?
Que también está lleno de
pequeños juegos de expectativas.
Como estos sutiles cambios en el tempo.
Ese ir y venir,
pero que tanta gracia dan.
O sorpresas más radicales.
¡Un nuevo vals!
Como les dije, la tradición está
en el inconsciente colectivo
y a través de gestos como este
un dos tres, un dos tres...
podemos reconocer incluso
un distorsionado y decadente vals
escrito antes de la Primera
Guerra Mundial.
¿No es como un fantasmagórico
eco de ese vals vienés?
Esas notas, al parecer inconexas,
son producto de años
de transformación de reglas musicales.
Wagner fue uno que contribuyó,
en su caso siendo un gran
manipulador de expectativas.
Música sugerente, llena de erotismo
donde cada nota, cada sonido
se aferra al próximo,
se arrastra y se adhiere.
Pero,
que cambia permanentemente de dirección.
No todo lo que suena puede ser inesperado.
Un silencio también puede ser provocador
y dejar preguntas abiertas.
El ensordecedor silencio...
Debussy y su sensual
"Preludio a la siesta de un fauno"
y ese sugerente silencio al comienzo.
El silencio, elemento
esencial de la música.
Más que ausencia de sonido,
es un recurso expresivo fundamental.
Y uno de mis silencios favoritos
es ese silencio cómplice.
Cargado de expectativas.
El que ocurre antes de que la música sea.
(Música)
Pero también cada nuevo silencio.
Regalando instantes de elucubración.
Siendo parte del discurso y conectando
ideas que pueden seguir creciendo.
Contrastes, estabilidad e inestabilidad.
Que, por cierto, la estabilidad del pulso,
y cómo lo agrupamos
es una reacción instintiva que aparece
apenas identificamos regularidad.
Un, dos, un, dos...
Pero, ¿y cuando ya ni siquiera podemos
anticipar esta agrupación?
¿Y solo nos queda estar
a merced de lo inestable?
Escuchar música muchas veces es como leer
una buena novela policial.
De esas en las que dudas hasta del muerto.
(Risas)
Y donde el nudo argumental y el inminente
desenlace te hacen más sensible
a cómo disminuye el grosor de las páginas.
Expectativas en el peso sobre
la punta de tus dedos.
El estado de atención cambia, es activa
y aceleradamente especulativo.
Ya no es "si esto, entonces lo otro".
Si no, "y si esto, ¿luego esto?
¿Esto, o lo otro?"
Como todo en la vida, en la naturaleza
del arte también está presente
esta idea de que hay que
esperar lo inesperado.
Pero ojo que lo inesperado no solo tiene
ese gustito de la primera vez.
Por algo volvemos a leer un clásico,
a ver una película
o a escuchar una y otra vez la música
que tanto nos gusta.
En parte porque nos gusta
experimentar desde la seguridad.
Como un niño que lee el mismo
cuento todas las noches
desde la tranquilidad
de saber cómo termina.
Pero además la relectura,
a través de la memoria
nos regala otros detalles.
Nos hace poner atención a otros lugares.
A escuchar ya no la melodía, sino
el acompañamiento por ejemplo,
y descubrir que esa hermosa música
había pasado desapercibida
aún habiendo estado ahí siempre.
Reconocer, pero también para redescubrir.
Un juego infinito de expectativas.
O la relación entre el intérprete
y el oyente, "¿cómo lo va a hacer?
¡Seguro que distinto a como aprendí
en la grabación que conozco!"
¡Pero esa es la gracia!
Si la música es un organismo
que respira y vive
en el instante mismo que suena.
Solo ahí la música es.
Y escucharla en vivo nos permite vivir
ese momento lleno de expectativas.
Cuando terminó el concierto,
mi papá me llevó a conocer al director.
Yo lo vi y me puse a llorar de nuevo.
(Risas)
Sin decir nada pensaba: ¡tú eres
el responsable de estas lágrimas!
Él me miró un poco descolocado.
Preguntó si pasaba algo,
pues muchas pueden ser las razones
del llanto de un niño de siete años.
Mi padre todavía emocionado le hizo
un resumen y al entender el impacto
que la música había tenido mí
el director me abrazó y me dijo:
“Bueno, por esto hacemos lo que hacemos”.
Ese día cambio mi vida.
Mis expectativas han sido desde entonces,
cambiar las de Uds.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)